Друзі, всім привіт!
Сьогодні я приїхав до Центрального управління поліції Бонна.
Німецькі правоохоронці мають високий рейтинг довіри населення.
Реформуванням поліції українці прагнуть досягти таких європейських стандартів.
Хотілося б дізнатися, скільки заробляють німецькі поліцейські,
як вони заслужили репутацію непідкупних, і на якій техніці вони працюють.
Ну що ж, ходімо всередину і подивимось,
як працює одна з найкращих поліцейських служб Європи.
Мене зустрічає перший головний комісар поліції Бонна Ґерд Петер.
Моє враження відповідає поширеному серед німців
уявленню про поліцейського як друга та помічника.
Комісару Петеру 57 років, з них 38 - він у поліції.
Після знайомства комісар показує центральну диспетчерську кімнату дорожньої поліції.
Коли колега отримує дзвінок від громадянина,
який повідомляє про дорожньо-транспортну пригоду,
на лівому екрані вводять дані про місце аварії та того, хто телефонує.
Система автоматично видає нам інформацію про те, хто з патрульних саме вільний і поблизу,
і ми по рації викликаємо їх на місце ДТП.
За допомогою схожої системи виїжджає і найближча до місця аварії швидка.
У середньому прибуття медиків і поліції у Німеччині до місця ДТП відбувається за 15 хвилин.
Цьому активно сприяють інші учасники дорожнього руху,
які зобов'язані утворити рятувальний коридор.
Обов'язково на місце аварії виїжджає ось такий мікроавтобус.
У ньому є все необхідне для фіксації місця ДТП.
Поки рятувальники і медики надають першу допомогу постраждалим,
дорожня поліція регулює рух, аби уникнути подальших ДТП,
і розставляє ці маркери для фотографування аварії для протоколу.
Уявіть, що тут сліди від ударів, розкидані уламки -
їх усі ми відмічаємо в позначених межах зони ДТП і фотографуємо.
І щоб все це потрапило в кадр,
звісно, необхідно підняти камеру вище -
у цьому допомагає ось такий прилад.
Дорожні поліцейські кажуть, що замість дрона
їм простіше і дешевше зробити фото загального виду аварії
за допомогою п'ятиметрового штатива і фотокамери на ньому.
А ще патрульні возять із собою ведмедика.
У нього немає імені, однак коли ми перебуваємо на місці аварії і зясовуємо,
що серед потерпілих є діти, які, звичайно, завжди багато плачуть,
ми даємо їм цього ведмедика, щоб вони трохи заспокоїлися.
Як правило, це таки допомагає.
Найшвидше і найлегше дістатися до місця ДТП мотоциклом.
Передавач у мне в шоломі, ось мікрофон,
тут же в шоломі вбудовані навушники,
усім цим я управляю кнопками отут.
А це дисплей рації.
Усього 19 кнопок - для синіх мигалок, сирени, сигналу зупинки.
Ось рація,
є місце для актів, потрібних, аби документувати аварії, фотоапарат.
А тут речі для регулювання руху.
Ось такий картуз, щоб мене розпізнали як поліцейського, коли я не в шоломі.
Жезл та інше.
Мені теж якось довелося мати справу з дорожнім патрулем.
В Німеччині я на собі відчув одну унікальну властивість місцевих поліцейських -
ти їх на вулицях не помічаєш, допоки не стається правопорушення.
Вони наче відчувають, де буде проблема, і виникають як з-під землі.
Я не користуюсь громадським транспортом і їжджу в Бонні на велосипеді.
Лише двічі за майже три роки на цьому велосипеді
у вечірній час не працювало освітлення -
і саме ці два рази мене зупинили поліцейські на патрульному на авто.
Штраф за таке порушення - 20 євро.
Однак я чесно пояснював, що проблема сталася тільки-но,
і мене відпускали з наполегливою рекомендацією штовхати далі велосипед пішки.
Звичайно, трапляються і набагато серйозніші ситуації.
Для цього у поліції завжди є з собою зброя.
Ось шафки для зброї, кожна з яких має свій персональний номер:
наручники,
це аерозольний розпилювач, більше відомий як перцевий спрей,
також пістолет з магазином набоїв.
Я повинен зарядити зброю для служби.
Тепер кладу пістолет в кобуру і готовий служити.
Використання вогнепальної зброї допускається лише в тому випадку,
якщо існує небезпека для життя,
тоді я можу використовувати службову зброю - мій пістолет.
Шахраї, злодії і наркодилери спричиняють найбільше проблем у Бонні.
Боннській поліції вдається ефективно протидіяти квартирним злодіям.
Завдяки пильності сусідів, патрулюванню і досвідченим слідчим
у 2017 році попередили кожен другий злам квартири.
Населення Бонна - понад 300 тисяч людей.
За криміногенною ситуацією - це одне із найспокійніших міст такого розміру в Німеччині.
Торік тут зафіксували найменшу кількість злочинів з 1996 року.
Понад 80 відсотків німців довіряють своїй поліції.
Так було не завжди.
Після Другої світової війни у Західній Німеччині через нестачу кадрів
у поліцію йшли служити ті, хто був поліцейськими і за часів націонал-соціалістів
і був причетним до злочинів режиму.
Відтоді  ситуація докорінно змінилася, і поліцейські заслужили довіру людей.
За словами головного комісара поліції Бонна,
початкова зарплата поліцейського,
який тільки-но прийшов після навчання і практики - 2200 євро.
З роками вона росте.
На питання про корупцію - відповідь чітка.
Нам категорично заборонено приймати будь-що.
Ми не можемо приймати жодних подарунків.
Це порівняно легко сказати: ні, мені не можна.
Ґерд Петер прийшов служити у поліцію практикантом у віці 19 років.
Теперішню молодь поліція землі Північний-Рейн Вестфалія, до якої належить місто Бонн,
серед іншого заохочує йти до своїх лав і каналом на YouTube.
Це серія про тренінг екстремального водіння.
Цікава деталь - у відеоблозі поліцейської можна розгледіти,
скільки у неї однакових сорочок у шафі.
А це перипетії чемпіонату із загартовування командного духу.
Серія про роботу в поліції знаменитої на весь світ німецької вівчарки.
А ця мелодія щонеділі у вечірній прайм-тайм збирає мільйони глядачів Німеччини перед телевізором.
Цей поліцейський серіал-рекордсмен Tatort - місце злочину, знімають з 1970 року.
Популярні детективи про поліцію виробляють 11 німецьких регіональних телекомпаній.
Кожна з них знімає серії про поліцію свого регіону.
Для 1400 боннських поліцейських події серіалу - робочі будні.
Диспетчерська отримала черговий дзвінок,
і патрульний виїжджає на виклик.
Про інші сфери життя у Німеччині дивіться в наступних серіях.
Пишіть у коментарях, що саме ви хотіли би побачити.
До зустрічі!